joining me now for tonight's retaking
america segment is mark bronovich he's
the arizona attorney general and a
united states senate candidate uh mr
attorney general thanks for for joining
us it is amazing how an election is just
months away and suddenly these democrats
are getting a backbone and saying oh we
got a problem but you know they weren't
there before were they
no they weren't and that's the reason
why uh i have been leading lawsuits
against the the byte administration and
their failure to secure the border and
all the lawlessness and the dangers
created our communities the reality is
and you know this jason there is a
political class in washington dc that
will say or do anything to get elected
and it's the reason why we need
responsible people in dc representing
american values and the reality is joe
biden and cartel kelly are trying to
impose some neo-marxist vision on this
country and americans are paying the
price not only at the gas pump at the
grocery store but literally with our
lives and the lives of our children and
it is a dangerous experiment that they
are trying to impose and i think that
there's this political conversion with
some democrats nowadays but but shame on
them they have enabled joe biden to
basically destroy our country in just a
year and a half
tell us about this temporary restraining
order that you're attempting to put in
place the suit that you put in place uh
to try to get the administration to do
what it's supposed to do
yeah you know jason you just mentioned a
tsunami um is coming to america and it
is if uh title 42 is lifted there will
be a tidal wave crashing on our shores
but it's not anything to do with climate
change or what joe biden was talking
about today in seattle it has everything
to do with the man-made disaster that
biden has done so when he stopped
building the border wall when he stopped
deporting people deportation owners when
he tried to lift the remaining mexico
policy now the last thing that we have
in place that's saving us from even more
illegal immigration even more crime and
drugs flowing into our country is title
42. so i have led a coalition we've got
20 ag's involved we have a hearing
monday in louisiana and we're hoping to
get a federal judge to say to the buy
administration no stop you can't do this
because american lives are at risk
because of cartel kelly and joe biden
wanting to enable the cartels instead of
protecting american taxpayers
it is truly stunning that the president
united states in all his time 50 years
being the president the vice president
and all his time in in the united states
senate has never been to the united
states border with mexico unbelievable
mr attorney general thank you for
joining us tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else